can't blame yourself for something a few
trick you might do well I don't
understand how I could do something like
that dirt Nora
[Music]
No
Know Who I am Barry
I don't know where you do Barry we've
been at this a long time you and I but
I'm always one step ahead
[Music]
it is your destiny to lose to me flash
just as it was your mother's destiny to
die that night
hey everybody its charlie we got new
flash footage to break down doing a very
obvious homage to season 1 reverse flash
vs flash battle at the stadium Norah
goes completely crazy so I'll try to
explain what's going on and I'll talk
about the john wesley shipp classic
flash costume from the 90s from that
promo that they released - there's a new
round of the flash ring giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a flash related comment on the
video I'll name a new winner at the end
of this so I'll talk about this footage
first then I'll talk about the John
Wesley Shipp 90s flash costume the big
thing here is that this is the episode
where they reveal what iris does in the
future
that's so terrible that Nora doesn't
want to have anything to do with her
because they've been teasing it since
the first episode she does everything
she can to avoid irises presence and
just spent all of her time with Barry we
saw her in the flash museum so clearly
she's been thinking about this for a
long time the title of the episode is
news flash that's a reference to how the
villain of the week's powers worked
her name is spin the description reads
Nora is targeted by a dangerous meta
Barry and Irish face the ultimate
parenting test when team flash battles
spin who has special Meditec in a
dangerous agenda for their daughter Nora
Ralph is feeling defeated until an
unlikely source issues a challenge to
help boost his confidence so the whole
idea is is the meta of the week's spin
targets Nora and you see her in the
background here like it says excess
kills flash obviously this is the meta
using her tech to hypnotize Nora in to
try and kill the flash which is because
they're doing the exact same scene from
that season 1 episode 9 reverse flash
versus flash battle they're not trying
to tell you that Nora is the flash or
anything like that there's still a
couple people that I see in the comments
of the videos that think that she's
secretly the reverse flash the way they
shot the flash Museum in last week's
episode put her like right in front of
the reverse flashes costume during a lot
of scenes especially when she was
looking at the future newspaper they're
mostly trying to visually reference how
he casts a shadow over everything that's
going on they're not trying to tell you
that he's secretly Nora or something
like that I still think that Nora is
Barry's daughter even though she might
not be telling everything
about what's going on in the future she
might have a couple secrets but I still
think that she's supposed to be Berry's
daughter there are a couple pictures
from the episode that show you what this
spin character looks like you can see
that Nora is clearly not a fan of her
just because the news banner that's
flying around the stadium says excess
kills flush I don't think that that
means the meta knows who she is because
in the comics the villains spin is
actually using a combination of two
different Metis powers to achieve the
same type of effect what he does in the
comics is get people to realize there
are worst fears and bring them to life
through his broadcasting network but
there's like the fear psychological
based aspect of the power like getting
people to freak out about stuff and make
it real then because he's a Titan of the
broadcasting world he has this network
of television stations that he uses to
broadcast that signal to anyone that's
looking at a screen so think people
looking at TVs at cellphones he
transmits this signal they bring their
worst fears to life so it's sort of like
a hypnotic effect and that's why Nora is
going crazy but you do wonder if this is
Nora's worst fear come to life or if
it's Barry's worst fear come to life
they're also these pictures of Barry
playing baseball for charity it's the
Central City Police Department versus
the fire department obviously he can't
use his powers when he's pitching I'm
sure they'll have some fun with that but
now that they've done baseball in an
episode and because Stephen Amell is
such a huge fan of baseball and Grant
Gustin - I'm hoping that someday they
could actually do the Batman Superman
batting cages moment from the comics if
you didn't read this this is actually
just them having fun going to the
batting cages together wearing each
other's costumes
so you see Superman wearing Batman's
costume because he's got his Clark Kent
glasses on on top of the cowl and this
is Batman wearing Superman's costume so
it's funny for a whole bunch of
different reasons but you have Lois Lane
and Catwoman in the background just
watching this go on
but speaking of crossover the whole deal
with John Wesley Shipp in the 90s flash
costume I think is that he's playing a
version of Barry Allen from another
earth because of the episode 13 from
season two when they were traveling to
Earth - they have a montage where you
just see all the earths of the
multiverse and flashes from different
ones like you see Supergirl you see the
Legion ring and you see a version of
John Wesley Shipp in his Barry Allen
costume from the 90s flash show meaning
that it's probably not Jay Garrick it's
actually
his Barre in there trying to canonize
the events of the 90s flash series by
saying that it happened in another
universe so my hope is is that they're
trying to do that during the crossover
they call it Elseworlds so I'm assuming
that this is not our Jay Garrick it's
Barry Allen from the 90s flash series it
even though it's kind of hard to explain
why he's not the same age as our Barry
Allen like there's Barry Allen's in
every universe there could be one that
looks like John Wesley Shipp there's a
little back bending that you have to do
maybe he did some time-traveling or he
had his version of flash rebirth and
he's already come back from the dead but
John Wesley Shipp the actor was talking
about the actual costume on social media
recently just praising the costume
designer like thank you so much for
doing this Marc Guggenheim thinking this
is the coolest thing that they've done
in seven years this is actually a new
picture from the crossover that he just
screened grabbed from all the footage
they've been shooting so this is
something that will appear during the
episode with him in an office talking
about whatever it is that they're
dealing with they have got to the point
in the crossover where they're shooting
Stephen Amell back in his green arrow
costume in Grant Gustin back in his
flash costume so it'll be interesting to
see how they explained this but if you
didn't see it there's actually a picture
of Tyler hoechlin when he's in this
black Superman costume reading from a
really ancient book that has the same
Flash symbols from the beginning of
season 4 and the ones that Nora was
writing in her books so the secret of
what the symbols mean might have
something to do with some of the big
twists during the crossover so if you've
been wondering what the big secret is
behind why those exist it sounds like we
won't have to wait too much longer to
figure that out but let me know what you
think about them including all these big
reverse-flash Easter eggs and references
and visual metaphors and episodes it
just feels like they're intending on
paying off brand-new face reverse-flash
sometime later this season I'm still
waiting to see how the events of these
episodes are going to spill into the
next arc because Kaitlyn's father seems
like the next big mystery that they're
going to uncover then after that maybe
they'll start paying off more
reverse-flash stuff they'll be more
Marvel soon there's a new Titans episode
coming on Friday so leave all your
requests in the comments below
congratulations gaming with Eric you're
the giveaway winner from my last big DC
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your contact
details click here for all my flash
episode 3 easter eggs and references and
click here for that new Iron Man
Avengers 4 teaser thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]